Speaker 1: OK, one more tour through the
evangelical televangelist insanity throughout
the pandemic, televangelist Kenneth Copeland
has been coming up with all sorts of bizarre
rants and raves about curing the pandemic.
This way that the vaccines are about all
these different things. This is a very weird clip
where he screams in order to kill the virus in his
colon. He's talking about the flu virus. Not, I
mean, when you say in the colon, are we talking
about viral gastroenteritis? It doesn't seem
like it. Take a look at this. And by the way,
at the bottom of the screen, if you need him
to pray for you, there's a number you can call
Speaker 4: and we'll help you
here with something. Yeah.
In the name of Jesus, a new
flu virus died in my colon. You die down.
Speaker 1: Now, if Saturday Night Live,
which I don't really find funny anymore, was
going to parody this. How could they do it?
He's actually up there saying die in my colon and
the congregation repeats die in my colon. How how
do you make a joke? How do you satirize that? It's
impossible. And the important message here is that
we should all remember Kenneth Copeland's entire
grift is tax tax-exempt because it's a church.
His six plus million dollar house,
where he lives with his wife, Gloria,
is exempt from property taxes. How well
it's listed as a parsonage. A parsonage is
a church house provided for a member of the
clergy. Sometimes, you know, like the old Catholic
Church down the street has a parsonage, and it's
often sort of like a very modest apartment of some
kind. His $6 million house is tax exempt from real
estate taxes because it's a parsonage. He tried to
get tax exempt status for his private jet that was
denied, but he still has a private jet. It just
not tax exempt and taxing churches would generate
about $71 billion per year if the United States
were to do that. So that's Kenneth Copeland. If
you said behind the scenes, Hey, I'm going to look
at how look at how sheep, how much of a of a
group of flock of sheep I have out there. I'm
going to go out there and say, die in my colon,
and they're all going to chant it with me.
It seems like a joke. It seems like a joke,
but it's unfortunately very, very real.